okay now today I wanted to talk about
efore v5 and the reason I want to talk
about that is many-fold but since I
teach a lot of kids classes this is what
I see a lot especially in this room
after the kids classes are over it's
it's an e4 e5 extravaganza now many of
you are familiar with Steve Davis the
snooker player right who was actually
look a little like him and he was good
in the early 90s when I lived in Belgium
and he was the best hooker player in the
world and there was a chess book written
in England where he wrote the forward to
the book because he's also a chess
player and he was explaining he played
chess as a kid and he was okay but he
had to quit because chess was too boring
and so he played snooker could go into
something a little less boring the
reason Steve Davis said chess was boring
is he said every game he played started
like this okay with with no exception
okay and he wanted to have like a
different openings or different kinds of
games and this was too boring
okay the truth hurts okay when you're
right you're right now the problem isn't
that chess is boring problem is he was
playing the most boring possible moves
with both sides and then he was
complaining it was boring so that's not
okay
so that position that I showed you
happens at about one third of kids games
and never happens at the Grandmaster
level because grandmasters have a little
more understanding of what we're trying
to do and in fact we're going to go back
half a move I was teaching class today
at a school and I explained that white
would like to go here and that shocked
one of the kids and I said the reason
you're playing e5 or c5 have you played
the Sicilian is when they play d4 you're
going to take it and one kid was very
happy about me saying that because he
said whenever they play d4 I never know
if I should take it
yeah well that's why you're playing e5
so you could take the pawn on d4 now you
don't always take the pawn on d4 but
it's a good rule to live by if you're
not sure then take things okay now I
want to talk about several things and
we're going to go back in time again
actually we're to go back times several
times then forward in time they'll be
like a Quinton Tarantino video or not
even clear what what era were in right
now okay
slightly less violent but only slightly
okay now in double King pawn when I
lived in Belgium in 1988 one of my good
friends there was international master
Luke Wynans who was the best player in
Belgium since he's become Grand Master
Luke Wynans
and also since some players from other
countries moved to Belgium he doesn't
play much anymore this was 25 years ago
him he was the leading authority in
Belgium on e4 e5 especially with black
and he told me if you want to be the
world champion
you got to play e4 e5 and I was thinking
back there's a lot of world champions
who didn't play e5 against efore in
their main repertoire but they still
played it occasionally and of course
there's a lot of great games where
Karpov is white and black in this
position Bobby Fischer of course almost
always play d4 and there are a few games
where he played ePHI but not many and
Kasparov of course won many brilliant
C's against Karpov playing e4 and has
also played a 5 and since we have this
discussion in the late 80s and early 90s
I think you remember pretty well I think
you were there at that time now every
top player in the world plays e45 it's
gotten more popular since we have this
talk the main reason is the Berlin
defense which has played at the top
level but at the lower levels is almost
never played and the Berlin defense is
in the real Lopez now one of the reasons
we see a lot of top level
Berlin's and we see very few at the
lower level is that lower level players
don't like the move Bishop b5 too
sophisticated okay they want to play
they want to play Bishop c4 and take on
f7 at some point they want to play d4
and sack all their pawns they're not
interested in Bishop b5 and playing this
long maneuvering game higher rated
players don't like to sacrifice their
pieces as much so we see lots of real
Lopez's now as you all know in 2000
there was a World Championship match
between which two players anybody you
that's correct
well how are you correct what feeling
all right all right
and and that match Kramnik introduced as
his main weapon the Berlin previous to
that the two leading practitioners on
the circuit where Alex Scherzer also
known as Alex not guilty Scherzer and
Arthur biz guy okay now Arthur busy ire
when he played the Berlin a draw was
okay and when Scherzer played the Berlin
he was playing for a win and they played
the same way where they would go into
this end game okay and this is the
so-called Berlin end game which I have
no reason to talk about today but it
happens to be very popular at the top
level and if you took all the top
players in the world they would have
this position with white and black just
not at the same time okay and that's why
II 45 became so popular
normally Kasparov would win with white
and when you play kramnik and the match
that you just revealed he did not win he
did not win one game and people said hey
if Kasparov can't win with why this must
be okay for black and since that match
they've been playing the Berlin okay now
I was actually very lucky okay because
when I moved to Belgium
I played efore c5 I put the Sicilian and
this was in 1988 and of course talking
to Luke Wynans I was introduced to plug
a 45 a lot and Luke plays a line that
nobody plays after Knight f6 he plays
Bishop c5 okay and what's good about
this for me is I was playing Knight f6
my opponent
I sold I played Bishop c5 then they
started thinking okay then kramnik
hooked me up as he's known to do kramnik
started playing Knight takes e4 so often
other players followed soon that this
became a very popular line and you could
argue this variation with Knight takes
e4 is as popular or more popular than
the normal a six now when I played
Knight f6 Bishop c5 nobody cared okay
they're like yeah whatever I don't know
anything then people started learning
Knight takes e4 because it became very
popular so now when I had this position
my opponents assumed I was going to play
Knight takes e4 because that became
popular this never became popular so
that worked out pretty well for me and I
still play this today and I still have
good results I've played it in US
Championships I've played it the club
I've played all over the world and I
have some funny wins and I'll show you
one today okay but I wanted to give back
to e4 e5 because basically there's this
story time today I want to tell you some
funny stories now let's say I want to
say friend I don't want to say
acquaintance I don't want to say enemy
enemies the closest game someone that I
know in Chicago gives chess lessons to
children this this position sorry you
know who it is and and this person was
teaching this position a lot because
this position happens all the time and
of course when kids are playing
especially kids rate under a thousand
Bishop c4 is the move of choice okay
as opposed to weapon of choice right
comer okay good plows essentially
yesterday working out all right so when
I analyze this with Fat Boy slim oh wait
a minute when I analyze this we were
talking about this position and he said
something funny to me he said I tell all
my students to play Bishop c5 and then
if their opponent plays 90 g5 attacking
f7 they take the knight and I said okay
that's good
and a lot of kids play 9 g5 because
that's the program to play Knight g5
they got a take out of seven now he said
unfortunately about 50% of the time his
students forget and play Knight f6 they
just can't remember to play Bishop c5 so
he tells his kids when you forget to
play Bishop c5 and this position occurs
you're going to play this smooth an
unknown move although it's known a
little bit not known of the people in
this room and the idea is if Knight
takes we play d5 and if white takes on
f7 it's very complicated and he would
analyze this with his kids of course if
you're a kid rated 400 and your opponent
plays Knight takes e4 you don't know
that move and his opponents would get
confused and they would do well okay but
there's a longer part of the story and
one of the stories is there is a coach
in Chicago I don't know who it is and he
told his kids
you should play Knight g5 and I'm like
okay the Knights hanging then he tells
his kids d4 now this is mastering the
middle game you have to master that your
queen is attacked and when I showed this
today in a school some of the kids took
with the pawn some took with a knight
and some took with a bishop but nobody
knows their queen was attacked and that
was the whole point so there's an
there's an educator in Chicago who
explains that in this position you're
going to take this Queen more often than
not unless you watch this video okay and
okay after d4 if you're just staring at
the pawn on d4 you can see how people
would miss Bishop takes g5 queen's eggs
g2 is not good for Wyatt okay now you
don't have to master the middle game you
could 15-under the middle game and still
win and now white loses everything
now this reminded me of a terrible movie
with a great actor and that movie is
anyone the illusion defense also a book
and the illusion defense stars John
Turturro not to be confused with
Nicholas Turturro who's not as not as
good okay and in that movie and
yesterday
chess club Mario of all people was
showing a trap and I was like Mario
showing a trap okay and Mario's trap
starts with the move Knight to d4 okay
now one of my favorite games of this
line is the game toxify Baja Mian one of
our you know previous g-man residences
was white and didn't know this move and
made the mistake Knight takes e5 and
after suspicious play by both colors the
game ended in a draw
although her opponent was 400 points
lower rated so okay of course every move
here is good for white except that one
c3 is good Knight takes Knight is good
and castles is good 9 takes e5 is
falling into the trap now in the movie
the loser defense where he's supposed to
be playing in a tournament
I mean whites not going to know world
chainage up level ok so the move
obviously is Queen to g5 now that there
is no knight on f3 to capture it and
White's greed has got it into some
precarious situation or got her in a
precarious situation as was happened in
the game and I don't know what talks
have did but the game will got really
crazy and ended up in a draw this game
was about five years ago now in the
movie and the trap that's in every book
is white continues to be greedy with 9
takes f7 another mistake queen's eggs g2
threatening the rook and also Queen
takes tricks pretty good so a rook F one
Queen takes e4 check the best move is
Queen e2 which gives the Queen away but
probably your typical player would play
Bishop e2 now when I showed this in
class today the first suggestion was 92
and when I said that was wrong the
second suggestion was Queen e2 also
wrong normally I get the wrong
suggestion of knights e2 which wins the
Queen and that would win the game but
there's a better move than all of those
moves which was pointed out by the third
student which is Knight f3 mate and that
was played in the lusion defense movie
because in movies Grandmaster games and
then five
okay so there's a lot of traps in e4 e5
if you're going to play e4 you fight
with either color you have to know these
kinds of tricks okay now I want to go
back because of course as soon as this
position occurred one of the kids yelled
fried liver fried liver okay this is not
the fried liver and I'm a vegetarian so
I don't want to hear it okay the fried
liver is assuming both sides make a lot
of mistakes okay and so you guys know
what I'm talking about right he's like
yeah a lot of mistakes me okay you can
put your hand out at home okay so Knight
f6 which is a reasonable move unless
you're Mike comer then it's just
terrible Knight g5 d5 now in this
position 90% of grandmasters would play
Knight a5 and maybe five or two Tambor
so I would play b5 or 94 remember some
crazy movies like it's b5 right all
right now in the fried liver black makes
the error Knight takes d5 and white
makes the error Knight takes f7 so
Knight a5 is the preference of all good
players in fact the first u.s.
championship ever held it the you at the
Chess Club saw the move Knight a5
between which two players does those
Alex are comer now Alex Nakamura versus
freed al that's correct
naka winning in what 23 moves not not
very long game
a miniature and naka won the tournament
ok but 9 a 5 is the normal move now of
course after Knight takes d5 d4 is very
hard to meet because the bishop is
protecting the knight and Knight takes
d4 loses a piece to c3 and your Knights
are all hanging so d4 sort of annoying
I've analyzed d4 but since I'll never
have white or black in this position I
didn't really care very much ok but
that's the move a grand minister would
play and then nobody would play Knight
takes d5 unless this was the year 1750
then ok maybe ok so in this position
some people want to play Knight f6
and after d3 which is just as popular as
95 at the top level black can choose
between Bishop e7 and Bishop c5 the idea
with this should be 7 is we can castle
in our Bishop won't get harassed on c5
we're going to keep it on e7 so there's
no pen and so forth
now because of this there's an opening
defense called the Hungarian defense ok
and that is very similar to the
Petrosian variation and my comers
favorite opening the qgd no nobody got
that ok Bensimon almost got that ok now
or as Mike would say the qg n now the qg
d the Petrosian variation is to play
Bishop e7 before Knight f6
which we could also do here so let's
play Bishop e7 the idea is if we Castle
Knight f6 and if Knight g5 we just
castle whenever somebody plays 9 g5
attacking f7 you want to castle if it's
legal that's not legal you could try
anyway okay now attribution should be 7
White has a very aggressive way of
playing d4 well I guess after castles
it's illegal d4 and c3 ok it may
surprise some of you that the most
common move for black and probably the
best is Alex well I said the best no I
think Knight a5 is better yeah solid
right ok
and after 985 it's unclear what should
happen but black is fine ok now when I
was 14 years old I had this position and
my opponent took on c3 which is OK and I
play Queen d5 and now he made a very big
mistake something none of the kids in
the kids class would ever do what did
black - that was a mistake
not only is 96 not a mistake
that's the only move see so maybe I
should ask for mistakes more often
you'll play better there is no other
move you must play 9 HX ok and instead
of 9 h6 what did my opponent do
while Knight f6 is pretty bad but he did
something even worse after 9 f6 I may
have died and then he would have won the
game
instead he resigned so even worse the
knight f6 okay and when he resigned you
know he could play Knight h6 like all of
you know defending mate and after takes
that I'm still threatening me but I've
won a piece and when he didn't realize
is he can castle here and the computer
engine say white is slightly better
white is up a piece but black has a
couple of threats
pawn takes h6 and pawn takes beats hero
and a good way for white supply is to
take defending b2 and then take on c3
materials equal blacks King is a little
funny but black has two bishops another
way for white supply is Bishop to c1
which of course I like as it retreats
and that defends the pawn and saves the
bishop now we have night before again
with a dual threat and the only way to
stop both if you'd like to stop both is
Queen d1 and then C two forks the pieces
for some reason in a previous class I
know if it was in this room one one
person suggested Queen d3 and one
suggested Queen d2 okay very suspicious
Queen do you want a safer okay now in
the hungarian defense normally after the
move Bishop e7 d4 black can play the
move D 6 and after takes you can take
with the pawn and after it takes you can
take with the bishop and ok I'd rather
have white but it's certain somewhat
boring and white doesn't have to take on
e5 y can simply develop so the hungarian
defense not popular at the top level
what is pop with the top level is Bishop
c5 also not popular is Bishop c4 this
should be 5 is far more popular now if
your opponent plays the Scotch with the
move d4 then of course there's only one
move to play as we discussed earlier in
class
you take it that's why you played the
movie five okay
now unfortunately or fortunately
depending on your point of view I was
analyzing a game today between some of
the kids and black played with I'd never
seen before
d5 trying to confuse the teacher I was
guessing taking on e5 was a good move
but white instead took and now made a
move that's very very very suspicious
Knight c3 is a normal move but he played
g3 not a good move black played Bishop
g4 this is really mastering the middle
again get all your pieces out and crush
your opponent white played Knight d2 it
didn't say which one then with these
guys I wasn't sure Knight takes d4
Bishop to G to c4 okay alright now in
this position black can win a lot of
material by playing Knight takes f3
check and if Knight takes f3 black just
takes everything Bishop takes check and
takes the rook ok beginner breakdown
instead black played Bishop takes f3 and
then they got to a position where black
was a pawn up he immediately hung his F
pawn and in this position which I'm
afraid to evaluate white made a move
they was so bad it was unbelievable I
would probably play C 3 white played
Knight see for opening this up for the
to the King and somehow black played the
best move here I was shocked
what is the best move you
you're 2/3 right change the F to
something else
my comer that was too easy for
comfortable okay
yeah actually yeah what was he thinking
will you people at home don't know what
you're missing
Lulu what should he do it's Lulu it's
not Knight f3 it's night-night b3 notice
how it's check which comer now notices
and attacks the rook and black one a
ruck and I can't show you the rest but I
would start crying but you would too
okay the point is d5 very suspicious but
not punished properly so the fortune
favors the brave something like that but
normally you would you would take this
and then if white takes we have a normal
scotch or black develops this piece is
one of two ways usually unless your
Steinitz and you buy this terrible okay
and also at the lower levels
people like to sack all their pawns
because they don't have any pawns left
yay
and white doesn't have any pawns okay
and this is some gambit of which I don't
know the name it's The Goring gambit of
the Scotch game but nobody knows okay
except those guys
mr. scotch okay now gambits are popular
at the lower level because they you've
done a politic see what happens every
game its Grandmaster level we don't like
to be done in e pawn so we don't do that
okay now let's get back to reality let's
look at a couple of games with this line
that Luke Wynans taught me since my
comer is actually in the audience I will
flip the board causing temporary
confusion alex Marler it's a 45 a
discussion
it's mastering the little game which
we're going to talk about now
okay now when I play Bishop c5 obviously
I'm not playing Knight takes e4 which
would not be good
mastering the little game does get to an
end game right away fact the last
tournament I played in a couple weeks
ago
I played three games all three games
were end games after move 15 some after
move 10 some earlier so there was no
middle game lecture from that tournament
so Bishop c5 now we're going to see a
middle game now there's two ways for
white to play white can play C 3 and d 4
which makes sense or white can play this
trick we've already talked about 95 and
if 95 then d4 and after 95 you can take
the knight on e5 like I just did or you
could take on e4 in fact I was playing
in with Ray Robson just when I started
working here actually and in Chicago and
he thought 35 minutes here or as Ray
Robson would say a short thing and
played the move Knight takes f7 which
actually has been played before
exactly yeah unfortunately so did I so
as the game continued I was better than
I was worse and then I lost and then he
got a GM norm and I didn't okay then the
next turn I get a GM norm and he didn't
and now I'm not sure who's better or
taller okay or lives in st. Louis okay
the answers to those questions are fried
green tomatoes all right and also Queen
e2 is the move that's the more common
move and I've played Knight takes e5 and
Knight takes e4 and I've done okay with
both but not against Ray Robson okay the
other way to play for white is to play C
3 and d 4 now I hope this is being
broadcast in England and Steve Davis is
watching us Steve your snooker games
okay okay but Knight c3 boring and
double King pawn openings white would
like to play C 3 and d 4 when you get to
the super grand master level d4 is a bit
much so you play d3 that you play d4
later
that's way a little slower magnus
carlsen approved okay and I Castle of
course and d4 now one thing tonight
got the kids today which they promptly
forgot was when your opponent plays C 3
and d 4 and a double King pawn opening
you have two possibilities you can move
your bishop or you can take the point
earlier I told you always take the pawn
ah the mysteries of life that's why
pencils have erasers you are going to
take this pawn when the White King is on
e 1 so in the Joko piano which is no
joke Bishop c4 Bishop c5 c3 ok now the
White King is on e 1 we take and play
Bishop b4 check and at some point we
take this pawn or play d5 or do both
depending on what white does and Black
has in theory equalized and the position
I'm showing you and the real Lopez where
White has already castled now we don't
take on d4 because if we take on d4 this
should be 4 is not check and there's a
very good reason to play c3 for white we
get to play d4 and it's defended but
there's a very bad reason the knight
can't go to c3 so if you trade pawns and
let White's Knight go to c3 White's just
can have a big Center so Bishop b6 is
the move and the idea is we're not
losing a pawn because your pawn is
attacked and a lot of the Berlin
variations when you take this pawn
you're very worried about your King on
i-84 King isn't on e8 you're not worried
anymore ok and white can take which I
faced this is the more common move
Bishop to g5 Luke went on sand I argued
for years about whether to play d6 or
play h6 and then d6 and we still argue
he thinks you shouldn't play h6 and I
think you should maybe he's changed his
mind in the last 20 years I know I
haven't yeah see he's right yeah so you
agree with me okay now after h6 there's
a funny line which I very rarely face
but it's funny they take minor e they
take my other night
then they take upon luckily this pawn is
hanging and I've actually had this
position more than once it's pretty
boring but you know it's e4 e5 what do
you want we want from me okay now most
of my opponents play Bishop H for
maintaining the pin and then I play d6
okay now uh in the last 25 years I have
two really nice wins against
grandmasters from this position both
games were very short one game was less
than 20 moves and one game was less than
25 moves and you would think with black
in this position you should never win
quickly because how do you master the
middle game when the game was already
all ending okay and one game was against
Boris cry-baby crimen and the other was
against joseph heller's joseph heller's
sounds like an author Ferdinand tellers
yeah I knew was somebody yeah I guess
that was a let's see kinda make a joke
about that I didn't prepare one so okay
thank you
so one game was played in 2002 World
Open where I got my first Grand Master
norm and my opponent played Knight BDC
would offer to draw okay now since I won
the game do you think I accepted the
draw what do you think nah he's paid
attention in my last class it was a
50/50 split 20 kids said yes 20 said no
and 20 voted for Pat Buchanan yeah now I
was like wait a minute
this Queen is protecting this pawn now
it's not so I took upon her a for me and
my opponent played as missions ugh
though the way some kids pronounced it
today I'm not sure they took missions
look-ins looks long and mixed them so it
was I was very confused okay now of
course if he takes my pawn I'll just
take back so he took my knight then I
play desicions again stead of taking his
Bishop I took his pawn then he played
his missions ugh
and I heard on the radio yesterday
desperado your favorite song right
he's like yeah okay and he must have had
an eagle eye to see this desperado
nothing they're just rolling over dine
at home okay so he played Bishop takes B
seven of course he takes my pawn and I
take his Bishop you can see that I have
seven pawns and he has six so before
taking on c3 he took this threatening my
rook I took and he took and if you count
the pawns I'll give you a minute six to
six okay but I want to win this point
this pawns attacked twice and it's
defended once sounds good right but my
knight is pinned so i unpinned by night
and now when he plays Bishop g3 I'm a
pawn up and I'll win with my two bishops
but my opponent wasn't so nice he
sacrificed a piece and now that pin is
sort of nasty I defended my knight he
attacks it again I played Queen e7 and
now he missed a chance to get his piece
back with the move e5 and everybody is
attacking everybody else very confusing
and the computer says that I should take
and then take and then play the crazy
move d5 and black is better I would not
have played d5 I think I would have
played Queen takes c3 yeah the idea
behind e5 is if he takes it then i
skewer his queen a knight okay in any
case instead of E 5 my opponent play
Queen e3 I played queen East Queen g3 I
play Queen e6 he played this terrible
move and now he did something shocking
my comer will never forgive him he
resigned yeah and the computer says
black is winning all right now that game
was played on board two of the 2002
World open in round 7 now before that I
was living in Europe and I played a
tournament a nice
is that your favorite country yeah
that's I agree with that okay and I was
playing either Ferdinand or joseph
heller's we'll never know
okay and the reason we haven't heard of
Ferdinand dollars except for you maybe
maybe is because he quit chess and what
did he do instead of chess he's an
attorney gay in his home country of
Sweden so he went from chess grandmaster
to Swedish attorney and in this position
instead of playing the Boris cry-baby
crime and move which led to a loss
eventually he took everything he took my
night he took my pawn and now he
defended his pawn with Knight BD - ok
now my pawn structure is a little
raggedy but I have a nice bishop ok and
now my pawn is attacked so I protected
it that's how I roll ok now I told you
this was a class of stories Luke went on
who showed me this line was playing a
tournament in your favorite city in
France although nobody in my last class
had ever heard of this city or could
name it it's the second biggest city
after Paris
pen Simon two for two okay Leon France
and as all of you remember in 1990 the
World Chess Championship between Karpov
and Kasparov was played half of New York
and half in Leon I'm sure you all
remember that especially those of you
who were born yet okay and when I was
playing this game in Reykjavik and
Iceland
my friend Lou Quinn honest was playing a
tournament Leon France turned out we got
home at the same time I mean like in our
apartments so I walked into my apartment
and my phone rang and I said hello
well maybe I said Bonjour you never know
I was in Brussels and he said hi this is
Luke I just came back from Leon I just
walked in the door and I just came back
from Reykjavik I walked in the door and
we talked about our tournaments and I
said I need Ferdinand howlers with black
and 23 moves and then he said you did
and he said Queen a4 and I said that's
right so just from what I told him he
figured out this position occurred and
white played Queen a4 that's why he's a
grandmaster and you're sitting in some
scary room right now so there's a reason
okay and I said how did you know now of
course today every game is shown live
with 500 commentators so everybody would
know but back then in 1988 he said he
had this position in Leon and his
opponent played like Queen e2 or rook e1
and they drew quickly and the guy said I
was thinking about playing Queen a4 but
that loses a piece my opponent played
Queen a4 and lost a piece so I did
better than one so now the student has
become the teacher now I could take this
night for free except for one thing the
other night what if I could attack this
Knight and make it move away hmm well
done so I played the obvious move pawn
g5 and when I play plunge e5 my opponent
put his head down and shook his head for
about a minute and a half
so I said well okay I thought he said
two-piece but I guess he didn't okay and
this ship to g3 and g4 and the game
ended pretty quickly I want a piece for
two ponds I can't remember the game
because I'm old but if I could remember
the game I would think it went something
like this what did he do now he played
here that's right doesn't make any sense
and here he resigned I think that was
the game yeah okay
it's like silk remember games I played a
long time ago as long as I won and there
was a very long complicated story okay
now this is actually removing the
defender but he removed his own defender
that was very nice of him because the
knight on D 2 has two defenders this
night and this Queen he moved one of
them away and I moved the other one away
well usually when I show this as a
puzzle my students say Bishop g4
attacking the knight and I'm like what
are you talking about the other and I
just takes back so that doesn't really
do it
pawns attacking Knights that'll do it
and when you're a grandmaster like me
you can move your pawn three spaces
ahead also just going to stop with here
right he's like I don't know maybe
sounds good right okay now you'll see my
book cheat like a grandmaster that's
coming out soon co-written by Boris log
even off alright who's not a grandmaster
terrible alright so I learned a lot from
a 45 from Luke Wynans
and what I like about this variation is
when I play Bishop c5 especially now my
opponents are expecting the Berlin
because everybody's playing the Berlin
now and then when I play here they're
not as familiar with Bishop c5 even
though it sort of looks like a joke Oh
piano it's a little bit different
because sometimes Y can try to win this
pawn sometimes black tries to win this
pawn and usually we just develop our
pieces then we get an equalist type
position of course I've had this many
times now I have to tell you something
funny I was giving a sign wall somewhere
where was i given the Simon I think it
was in South Carolina yeah they're in
the news lately right Clemson and all
and my opponent played rookie one and my
Simon that I gave and actually this was
played in the game of gold goes where he
played Knight g4 might come a
recommended attacking f2 and after a
rookie to 9 to d4 game we trade and
actually black can play Queen h4 and h5
and get a big attack while white is
asleep here this looks like everybody
who ever lived versus Morphy okay and
Gokul won his game and I won my game in
like 12 moves and I remember there was a
theme where upon at some point we'll
make some illegal moose for white my
opponent played h3 and then in some
position
I played Queen g3 this was the key theme
of the game
notice Quan takes Queen is illegal
because it's illegal and this is going
to be me and if my opponent takes I got
a nice rook over here to also help me
meet you okay and I had some game like
this an assignment which ended in like
10 moves okay although I'm pretty sure
my opponent didn't play a three rip D
through a two
well they might have played worst moves
it's not clear yeah so rookie ones not a
good move in any kind of opening like
this when there's a bishop at night
bearing down on you
my comer would agree normally when
you're playing rook e1 there is no
Knight g4 there is no Bishop c5 and
you're just helping your knight swing
around here what English up diet good
job so I've had a lot of success with
e45
but I still play it rarely I prefer c5
the Sicilian and obviously pizza related
you know arguments and when I was a kid
I played the French defense every game
so I went from playing the French to
playing the Sicilian to playing E 5 to
sort of playing the Sicilian more now
and now that I'll play often I like to
play all three not at the same time but
if possible and sometimes this is even
even a 45 these openings all look like
each other okay and I've had some
Sicilians lately that look like a 45 I
don't know how it happens it always
happens in these Bishop b5 lines okay
my opponents think they're playing the
real Lopez even though it's Sicilian
okay and we get these positions and it
reminds me of a 45 especially when
something silly like this happens and
I've had positions like these and this
looks more like a 45 and e4 c5 so and a
lot of my Sicilians and French's look
like each other I'm sure Alex Marlar
would agree often you're playing east
six nc5 and you're not even sure where
the opening came from when I was
analyzing with a listen Allah Khanna we
would look at the advanced French of the
Sicilian because she was playing white
and we would sometimes get positions
that looked like this the advanced
French because sometimes she was playing
C 3 against the Sicilian her opponent
would play e6 and we would get these
positions okay they would transpose so
even if you play only e4 e5 or you only
play the Sicilian you only play the
French sometimes it looks like other
openings and having a general knowledge
of those openings can help you in the
middle game with what the right plans
are just showing one opening is it
enough when things start to look
differently and the last thing I'll say
is although it's not e45 a lot of times
in the Smiths Morra a lot of good
players are playing Knight f6 or they're
playing some other variation declining
the gambit and you have to know C 3
Sicilian type positions so even if it's
Eve 45 and you're ready for the real
opaz the Joko piano the scotch there's
other things like the vienna and the
king's gambit which we didn't talk about
today which you won't face very often
but if you do and your opponent knows it
better than you do you better be ready
for that
so e4 e5 looks boring looks symmetrical
but there's a lot of poison there's a
lot of different variations
and anybody who's watched beginner
breakdown or as I call it beginner
beatdown they know when the night comes
to g5 and attacks f7 this is not a
boring opening thank you for coming to
whatever this lecture was called and
I'll see you guys on Thursday